. We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P..
We're getting a lot of of calls like this.
People convinced Trump not only one, but he
will get four more years.
Take a listen.
Donald Trump being a wonderful person, you're
damn sorbo delivery there was for a man is
so obvious, man.
You deem and pass laws.
There is going to be four more years of Trump,
boy.
Yeah.
Now, for people thinking that can't possibly
be real, that's clearly someone from Massachusetts
joking with you.
That's a it's a caller.
We know the number they call from is a legitimate
West Virginia number.
And we are seeing these posts everywhere.
We're seeing them on YouTube, we're seeing
them on live streams, people continuing to
post Magga.
Twenty twenty, Trump twenty twenty.
Trump lost.
What on earth are you talking?
It's over.
I mean, there's no the thing we're moving
on Joe Biden is he's almost fully staffed
up at this point in time.
These people are going to be around for a
while.
I believe they will be with us for some time.
We will talk on the bonus show today about
the Supreme Court decision about limiting
attendance at houses of worship due to the
virus.
We will talk about vegans at higher risk for
bone fractures.
Producer Pat will weigh in on this explosive
new veganism story.
And we'll also talk about the plan to reduce
massive wildfires.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at Join Pakman dot com.
I will see you then.